Russian forces have stepped up their
assault on a small salt mining town in
eastern Ukraine with the help of a group
of mercenaries the Wagner group is now
claiming control over solidar's City
Center or the Kremlin says its forces
are making progress around the town but
Kiev says its soldiers are holding out
Natasha Butler is joining us live now
from Kiev and Natasha what more do we
know about solidar
well the situation in solidar is not
totally clear what we know is in the
last few minutes Russia's defense
Ministry has said that Russian Airborne
forces are surrounding this Eastern
Ukrainian town from the North and the
South earlier we heard from the head of
the Russian mercenary group Wagner now
yevgeni pregojin claimed that his troops
were in control of solidahi posted a
photograph of himself with some of his
Fighters online but of course none of
these claims can be verified Ukrainian
defense officials for now say that their
troops are still fighting intense
battles that they are undergoing
assaults from Russian forces on the
ground so it's an unclear picture in
solidar but what we know is uh over the
past few days officials at Britain's
Ministry of Defense have said that they
do expect Soledad to perhaps come under
a Russian control in the following days
now if that happens from the Russian
perspective it would be something of a
Battlefield game they certainly haven't
had one for many months and it would
also open up the way for them to make
their way and really focus on the town
of bakmut which is not far from Soledad
it has been the focus of intense
fighting between Ukrainian and Russian
forces for many weeks many months now
Russians want to try and control the
city any Victory there would be symbolic
for them but again Ukrainian officials
are saying that their troops on the
ground are putting up a stiff resistance
they're still very much holding their
positions and in order to try and
augment those troops in the ground we've
been hearing uh from Ukraine's foreign
minister I believe that the country
still needs heavy armored vehicles
they're going to be questions about
whether or not they're going to get them
from European countries
well indeed uh you know officials both
in Kiev and in Europe say that what they
expect to happen perhaps in the coming
weeks in the coming months is for Russia
to try and launch a new offensive and
that is why Keith keeps saying look we
need uh more weapons all sorts of
weapons of course not only MSR defense
systems we know that for example some
Ukrainian troops are going to be trained
on those Patriot systems in the United
States in the coming week according to
U.S officials Ukrainian officials say
they also need things like heavy
Weaponry tanks in particular that's
something that Ukraine's foreign
minister said to Germany's foreign
minister when she visited uh eastern
Ukraine on Tuesday it has always been
though a very controversial topic for
Western Powers they don't want to be
seen to be sending offensive weapons to
Ukraine but the door has opened there
has been a shift because France uh began
said that it would send a light combat
vehicles to Ukraine we're now hearing
also from the UK that they're
considering sending their Challenger two
tanks and pressure is growing on Germany
to sign off on various European
countries that have their german-built
leopard tanks to be sent to Ukraine that
is what many European countries are
saying they would want to do send those
leopard tanks to Ukraine but Germany
does have to sign off on them because
they are german-built and so far the
German Chancellor Olaf Schultz has been
reluctant to do so he doesn't want to uh
Germany to look as if it is in any way
escalating this war or send what he
might regard to be the wrong signals to
Russia talking to us from Kiev there's
Natasha Butler Natasha thank you very
much indeed